bonsoir jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france comment est-ce
que vous qualifieriez vous la relation
entre vladimir poutine et emmanuel
macron les a entendus se tutoyer je
crois plus très souvent sauf si vraiment
il ya b mais d inimitié profonde canton
sans ambiance du toit mais c'est une ré
le général il faut c'est bien dans ces
temps ci une positif sur les relations
bilatérales
donc c'est une arme est ce une marque de
confiance ce mot a été employée par
emmanuel macron un espace un agenda de
confiance qui avait été établi au fort
de brégançon lors de la précédente
rencontre entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine s'est on est sur ce
chemin de la delà de la durée
tablissements de la confiance entre ces
deux pays
je crois que briançon a joué un rôle
très important effectivement d'abord
tirer bat hull brigands semblerait pas
eu tutoiement parce que pour arriver au
tutoiement il faut éviter les reins des
passes et des réunions des trop formels
et donc c'est à brion semble péter et
puis ensuite je crois en effet une
certaine confiance et en 30 secondes
alors pour quelle raison justement ces
relations semblent aller sur le chemin
de l'apaisement est ce à cause de la
distanciation sans mauvais jeu de mots
bien sûr avec les états unis en ce
moment mais l'apaisement il a commencé
il a commencé en fait de même avant
brégançon vision brégançon été le point
d'orgue
là en l'occurrence il s'agit plutôt
d'une reprise de contact après un gel
total de presque trois mois plus de
trois mois même en fait il sait
pratiquement rien passé depuis la
réunion à paris 9 décembre du sommet
normandie sur sur l'ukraine il sait
pratiquement rien passé je dirais même
il s'est plutôt passé des choses
mauvaises parce que enfin moins bonne
parce que j'attendais beaucoup à une
relance de la négociation du pagne est
né en fait on voit bien que c'est
difficile
les présidents se sont peu parlé du
confinement
la situation a évolué
en libye dans des proportions qui sont
pas forcément satisfaisante des hommes
pour la russie pour la france donc
donc en fait trois quatre mois non
seulement les contacts ont été
interrompues en tout cas à peu près et
mais la cité internationale n'a pas
évolué très favorablement ni pour les
uns ni pour les autres
donc c'est le moment de reprendre
contact de travailler ensemble en misant
en se fondant sur la confiance qu'avait
et et amiable à brigue ans alors ce
dossier libyen vous l'évoquez 1 c'était
là la priorité également de cette
reprise de contact pour emmanuel macron
reprise du dialogue et les deux pays
sont d'accord on sait que la france
soutenait officieusement plus tôt le
maréchal haftar quelle est la position
de la france aujourd'hui est de la
russie son talent sur la même ligne mais
je crois que quel sens on avait vu line
en ce sens qu'elles sont également
ennuyé par l'évolution de la situation
parce que ni la russie ni la france
n'ont renoncé à soutenir le gouvernement
appuyé par l'onu quel est le
gouvernement mais en même temps l'un et
l'autre pays valorise la capacité
j'allais dire anti terroriste de naphta
bien lutté avec un certain succès contre
contre un beige
donc en fait d'eux les deux les deux
pays font face à une problématique que
un peu identique un gmail n'aimerais pas
l'élimination deux acteurs ne peuvent
pas renoncer à soutenir le gouvernement
reconnu par la communauté internationale
la différence c'est que avec les groupes
wagner et des avions sur place des bus
sont plus impliqués dans la situation et
militaires et c'est la même chose
également pour le dossier syrien est la
france qui compte sur son partenaire
russe en tout cas pour acheminer ce pays
vers des élections
je dois dire
j'ai tendance à penser que sur le
dossier syrien
on n'est qu'à un point d'élection qu'il
y aurait une certaine de jeu un certain
temps on de légitimation internationale
je pense que on va parler de la syrie
bien sûr mais le disons qu'il va y avoir
un problème humanitaire sans doute de
habib encore que notre situation soit
gelée par une sorte d'accord relecture
aînés et les rues mais les français là
non et ils ont des préoccupations
humanitaires et le moment venu peut-être
dans cadre d'un accord global on pourra
parler de la syrie
mais pour l'instant on attend pas grand
chose pensant aux élections en syrie
dans les circonstances actuelles on a
entendu le président emmanuel macron
parlé de l'importance de la stabilité en
europe de de lisbonne à vladivostok 7 ce
sont les termes qui avait été employé
par le général de gaulle
en cette année de célébration de
commémoration en tout cas du général
c'est important ces mots
prononcée par emmanuel macron pour la
russie je crois que c'est très important
c'est un peu le la base de l'appel a été
lancé le président à publique française
à la construction d'une architecture
nouvelle de sécurité en europe
une architecture nouvelle de sécurité ça
c'est de lisbonne à vladivostok c'est
très clair et donc que par son caractère
heures asiatique là elle la russie était
inclus dans le dans l'europe ce que de
vous le verrez pas 10 parce qu'il parle
de l'atlantique à l'oural
donc je pense que c'est un des piliers
de la politique du président macron je
pense que ça correspond à une demande
d'ailleurs de la diplomatie russe depuis
longtemps cette idée de maison commune
qui avait été mis en avant par mais je
pense effectivement que pour eux
comment c'est un vrai travail dans le
domaine il faut déjà commencer à régler
deux lacs résultat net et et la france
seraient plus enclines en tout cas à
adoucir sa position les sanctions ont
été reconduites l'a dernièrement au
niveau européen quelle est la position
de la france sur la crimée notamment jeu
alors la crimée vous avez noté que même
du temps du président olemps de la
crimée ne fait pas partie elle est même
pas mentionné donc en fait le vrai
problème c'est le sel dont basse donc
c'est que c'est là que pas de là peut
partir l'étincelle qui pourrait relancer
n'a mis que de crise en europe est là
pour le pour l'ukraine le sien est
difficile
j'ai dit à l'heure depuis trois mois on
sent un durcissement vous côté du côté
ukrainien
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on attendait
de l'accord du 9 décembre qui ne se
réalise que difficilement et le prochain
gros la prochaine réunion du sommet
normandie en formation de chefs d'état
devait avoir lieu à berlin est reportée
non seulement à cause du gros navires us
mais parce que on ne voit pas quel
résultat contraire peuvent en sortir
en l'état actuel des choses emmanuel
macron qui est invité donc en russie
prochainement
vous pensez que les dossiers en cours
seront toujours les mêmes a annoncé sur
ces fameux dossier et se rapprocher et
rétablir cette confiance avec la russie
alors j'ai constaté une différence
intéressante encore des dossiers mis en
avant par le président russe est aussi
mis en avant par le président français
le président russe
il a mis en avant l'idée de travailler
sur le climat sur les questions
environnementales sur le terrorise et
aussi sur les questions de la pandémie
alors c'est intéressant parce que ce
sont des sujets qui sont vraiment
consensuel je crois qu'il ya vraiment un
peu de différence
donc on peut faire des choses c'est des
sujets de de coopération du côté
français on a mis l'accent sur les la
relance du multilatéralisme la question
de du sommet ddd membres pour s'exécuter
deux membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité mais on a parlé aussi des
crises et crise et le président français
a cité la libye la syrie et est bien sûr
que le l'ukraine l'ukraine est donc ça
ça veut dire une vraie discussion deux
fois dans des conditions tu allais dire
2 de franchise où on met tout sur la
table ou rediscute sont pas des sujets
qui semblent consensuelles à tout moore
en tout cas en tout cas sur l'ukraine et
probablement sur l'a6 sur la vie on va
peut-être arriver à se mettre d'accord
compte tenu de la position un peu ambigu
des deux parties que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
donc en fait il y a à la fois la volonté
de créer de la confiance par des sujets
qui a priori sont transformés elle
et puis il ya aussi la volonté en tout
cas du côté français de le mettre sur la
table des dossiers où la confiance créé
serait mise à profit pour faire avancer
le fondateur merci beaucoup jean de
gliniasty d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte france